on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonado PS on sensor first the claim
now the fight back Israel says it can
prove it was not to blame for the
massive explosion of the Gaza hospital
and President Biden agrees I'll talk
live to the Palestinian ambassador to
the UK and we'll debate how far should
the US go to back Israel in this
war
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Pier Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Pi Morgan
uncensored much of the world throw its
support behind Israel in the wake of the
Hamas attacks of October the 7th
landmarks from Downing Street to the
Empire State Building and the
Brandenburg gate were illuminated the
colors of Israeli flag quite rightly it
can't be repeated enough that was a
terrorist attack and the worst mass
killing of Jewish people's since a holl
caust but as the Israeli response now
intensifies that backing will inevitably
be tested and challenged as we've
debated on this show what is the
proportionate response to acts of Terror
like that and who should get to decide
that Israel knows it needs the full
support of its allies and this push to
wipe out its enemy Hamas the
Palestinians know that too and the
result is a dangerous fog of war with
both sides making claims and counter
claims apparently living in completely
alternate realities last night the world
was shocked by this
we are now learning that hundreds of
people have now died in a strike on a
Gaza Hospital Israel has thrown any
caution to the wind 500 Palestinians are
said to have been killed in an explosion
one of the most deadly attacks of this
conflict so far between 200 and 300
people were killed in a bombing
targeting a hospital that's according to
a spokesperson for the Palestinian
Health Ministry well authorities in Gaza
City which is controlled by Hamas said
an Israeli rocket destroyed the hospital
killing 500 people as I said at the time
if true this would be a major turning
point in the war and the consequences
were immediate Jordan canceled a summit
with President Biden mmud Abbas the
Palestinian Authority president canceled
his meeting with Biden too condemnation
poured in from everywhere then it began
to get a little more complicated the
Israelis first denied that any hospital
was a Target then said the rocket was
fired by Palestinian terrorists they
said it misfired and landed in the
hospital car park and they have the
evidence to prove it tonight the White
House said it's seen that evidence and
that it agrees this was President Biden
shortly after arriving in Israel today
was deeply sadden an outrage by the uh
explosion at the hospital in gazi
yesterday and based on what I've seen it
appears as though it was done by the
other team not not you but there's a lot
of people out there not sure so we got a
lot got overcome a lot of things well
it's not a game there are no teams here
it's a deadly serious War but the the
other serious Point here is that russan
to judgment is a big mistake October the
7th was a terrorist attack this is a war
and in times of War we have to look
twice at everything maybe three times
news outlets like the BBC rushed to send
push notifications and break news about
a wicked supposed Israeli attack now the
BBC's own verify unit is citing a large
pile of circumstantial evidence that the
blast originated in Gaza and none of it
in fact came from Israel in these feal
times we should trust sparingly and
question everything and remember this
whoever did blow up that hospital a lot
of innocent and vulnerable people died
to discuss the war in Gaza I'm joined by
the Palestinian ambassador to the UK
usam zlet Ambassador thank you very much
indeed for coming in I do appreciate you
taking the time particularly at a time
like this to to come to the studio you
were very active on Twitter from the
moment that this hospital was uh hit uh
you said it's a massacre hundreds are
killed in Israeli strike uh on the
hospital hundreds of medical staff
taking Refuge how long will it take to
stop these atrocious war crimes you then
say waiting for UK government
condemnation of this atrocious Act of
mass murder after being directly hit by
Israeli air strike and you Carri it on
when Kia starma uh said the scenes of
hundreds killed at the hospital in Gaza
are devastating can't be justified
international law must be upheld but
didn't mention Israel you said why can't
you condemn this why is it so harest
someone with a background in human
rights law is it because the victims are
Palestinian so you were in No Doubt last
night this was an Israeli air strike and
yet I watched the BBC News this evening
they did an extensive investigation of
everything that's available at the
moment by their verify unit specifically
designed to cut through any partisan
rhetoric and get to reality and based on
circumstantial evidence as they said but
the the clear conclusion of that
investigation is it's far more probable
that this was actually fired from within
Gaza it was a misfire and it landed in
the car park next to the hospital and
they site for example the the crater is
Tiny by comparison to the kind of crater
you would see from a conventional Israel
missile uh and so on what is your
response to that have you changed your
absolute conviction that this is an
Israeli air
strike before I answer your question pi
um today is the first day of our
national morning for uh the killing of
hundreds of innocent
people and in me in memory of those
hundreds of doctors nurses medical staff
patients cancer
patients uh uh patients with kidney
failures
children innocent people who took refuge
in a Baptist sponsored Hospital the
Anglican and many of all of those who
were
killed last night allow me to have a
moment of
silence now back to your
question this very same
Hospital the
Baptist ahly Hospital of Gaza was
bombarded only two days before last
night by the Israeli air strike and they
recognize that this very same hospital
was designated by Israel as a place to
be evacuated this very same Hospital the
director of it was called by the Israeli
occupation authorities asking him to
evacuate all patients on mass but that's
not my question no no no that's no no
I'm I'm I'm answering your question and
allowing me to answer my question is are
you still as sure as you were last night
I'm answering I'm answering your
question I believe the Archbishop of
Jerusalem when he condemns the Israeli
air strike I don't believe the Israeli
mouthpieces and spokes people they lie
more than they breathe and this is their
record is very clear number number three
number three you think groups in Gaza
have
such you know uh precision and fire
power really I don't think it was
precise the point if you look at it you
at with respect you look at the BBC you
look at the BBC investigation they
include footage which seems to show a
rocket misfiring let's have a look let's
have a
look there's no
sound you see it you see it go up and
then you see a ball of fire and it looks
like and this was the BBC's conclusion
based again on circumstantial evidence
that this was fired from within Gaza it
misfired it then landed in the car park
next to the hospital now all I ask you
this Ambassador I am an ambassador I'm
an official and I tell you with
certainty this was an Israeli air strike
where's your evidence I have the
evidence and you will see the evidence
where is it I'll tell you what's my
evidence my evidence is that we are
calling for the Red Cross to come and
investigate this and for the IC and
until now the Red Cross has the
responsibility at such war crimes who's
who's blocking the the the the Red Cross
anyway we have very strong Civil Society
human rights organizations on the ground
we are communicating with them tomorrow
you will hear from everybody and you
believe you will produce evidence isra
we have yes we will yes we will why
would the
American question ask don't ask me about
the the Americans the Americans why
would the president of the United States
say that his own independent
investigation by his own people I not
the not the intelligence given to him by
the Israelis that has also established
it came from within Gaza is that a
serious question P really you think the
Americans are you think he's lying
President Biden yes he is lying he is
lying and he is part of that's a big
charge to make about he has he has just
lied before getting any evidence there
is no way seen I don't know if he's seen
evidence he said he he doesn't have
Personnel if he has Personnel he must
Pro provide protection for our civilians
then he is complicit in the crimes
against when you see that video what do
you think you're B is what do you think
you're saying he it's whitewashing and
gaslighting as we have been seeing over
de and uh well what if I am wrong bring
me again here okay bring me again here
and then we'll discuss it no one has
such Firepower except the Israeli but
have you seen theat have you seen the
crater Army and you know what no one
even in the region has such
Firepower very sophisticate have you
seen theat I have seen I have B I have
does that crat to not tell you it was
not an Israeli air this is the trick
I'll tell you what happened Israel did
it Israel thought the world was giving
it the green light that it was okay to
do so but when we did it they did not
expect the outcry and then they did it
again as they do all the time why is the
crat so as as they do all the time they
simply go out and deny it blare the
lines two stories we don't know and I
will remind you few weeks from now or
few months Israel will come out and
admit it but it will be too late they
will not get the I don't think they I
don't think they will they will they
will admit it as they did in the past in
the past they have denied many things
and have you seen out of Interest have
you seen the BBC verify investigation
I did you watch that tonight you know
the BBC is is is to be blamed for part
of this because the BBC just run one day
before that Hamas digs tunnels
underneath hospitals primarily speaking
instigating the Israeli idea another
another indication that they did it that
they should go after hospitals which is
a war crime as you know very well
defined now where is the issue here what
is the main issue here is that all these
lines that have been happening over the
years are not challenged by you pierce
you and all the main stream completely
untr no no it is all that says to me is
You' never you've never seen me on I
have seen you I have seen your interview
me years I have seen your inter you seen
me interview net twice I I have seen
your interview just a few days ago with
Israeli Ambassador she did say here on
this seat on this seat that they
provided the whole south of Gaza as a
safe Zone and they are building shelters
to Palestinian civilians she told you
that and I said there was did you
challenge her I said did you challenge
her I challenged her like this no you
did not challenge her you did not
challenge her
I'll tell you my sister she denied there
was a humanitarian crisis I said there
was no no you didn't yes I did no you
didn't yes I did you started you started
that conversation with her with showing
and outpouring emotions good for you
about the mothers why didn't to start
with me about the thousands of mothers
grandmothers literally read that
literally with me Ambassador this is the
asymmetry this is the as that she lied
she lied with you let me be clear and
she said that the south of Gaza is safe
you know how many people were killed in
the south of Gaza only in the last 48
hours you know that my sister now she
lives in the south of Gaza and I you're
following my Twitter look at my nephew
Amar you saw Amar you saw what happened
to Amar they live in the south so an
Israeli official sits here and tells the
world that the Gaza the south of Gaza is
safe and people should go there on mass
therefore ethnically cleansing these
people to the to the South to actually
actually uh slow Ved them and then you
peers do not look her in the eye and
tell her stop lying I was on the BBC
Sunday morning just couple of days ago
uh with the foreign secretary and others
before me was another Israeli mouthpiece
spokes person Mark re he said we did not
and will not Target any hospitals they
lie all the time but just to be clear on
the hospital there is a
clear circumstantial set of evidence
which is the been established now by the
BBC by the independent verify unit they
don't have any SK you think that was the
first time Israel targets a hospital
appear no I'm not saying that I'm just
talking about last night's atrocity
which is what it is because hundreds of
people have died there remains a massive
question mark over whether Israel had
anything to do with it what about the
other 2,800 well let me come to this all
right what about the other let let's
let's come to this so I want to take you
back to October the 7th because you were
very quick last night when you believed
it was is air strike that have committed
this horror which had killed several
hundred people we're not entirely sure
of the exact death toll yet but
certainly hundreds of people appear to
have died you were very quick to demand
that everyone from K starma to others
publicly condemn what had happen of
course so let me take you back hang on
let me take you back to October the 7th
this no no I'm not playing anything
don't play this don't play this if you
are in I wanted what I wanted my
question okay I know where you're going
but want to exp I don't think it takes a
genius to work out where I'm going but
let me ask a question first then you can
respond please okay okay my question is
this you're very very keen to demand
that political leaders in including saki
starm here publicly condemn yes an
attack on a hospital which may not have
been Israel right and you repeated that
throughout your your evening on Twitter
right that's true but what you have are
not prepared to do yourself as the
ambassador to the UK because I've
checked your Twitter feed and you've not
done this and to my knowledge you've
done this in public you're not prepared
to condemn Hamas for the slaughter of
1,400 innocent people in Israel on
October the 7th so I give you the chance
given that you want others to condemn
acts that kill people even if they're
not responsible given that Hamas have
brazenly admitted responsibility for
what they did are you prepared to
condemn it you you know this game and
this narrative it's a g it's a game it's
a game I'll tell you why should you
demand condemnation allow allow me
people dying not be prepared me to
explain it to you and to your viewers
why it is a game and a very vicious
unfair asymmetric game that has
contributed to the oppression of my
people for 100 years MH number one you
know our position you know that Hamas is
just a militant group that was created
20 30 years AG is it the
terrorist you asked me this question
okay what is the definition of terrorism
I'll just ask you you think the
definition of terrorism I'll give you
I'll give you the I'll give you
the I'll give you I'll give you the the
def the international United Nation
definition of terrorism it is the
unlawful use of violence against
civilians to ter terrorize them for the
sake of a political agenda agreed
agreed unlawful violence against
civilians do you and answer me please
well no I've asked do you consider do
you consider Israel to be a ambassador
to be with respect I'm ask a terrorist
state do you consider Israel to be a
terrorist state if you if you won't
answer me why should I answer you did we
agree did we agree on the definition of
terrorism I I've asked you isass a
terror Israel has been targeting
civilians in front of your eyes for 7
why should I answer any of your question
you answer mine deliberate targeting and
not just this this round 2014 you know
all that happened 2,500 I'm very aware
of the history then you be very critical
of isra Israel a terrorist state I'm
asking you the question is Israel a
terrorist state ambassador this is the
answer me and I'll answer you
about it's not how this works it's my
show a GU it is from now on this is the
way it works there has to be equity and
you are the ambassador to the United
king we are I'll ask you a question I'll
ask you your question you are the
Ambassador I am proudly so proudly so I
I'll ask you a question and you've been
here I think since 2018 you've been
Ambassador for 5 years right yes and I
was in the US before right and the UK
government has Hamas identified as a
prescribed terror group do you agree
with that
that's that's the UK business you agree
no no no the this is not about me
agreeing or agreeing I'd like the the UK
to designate the kahanist in the Israeli
government as a terrorist group you may
want other groups as a terrorist group I
want to see but as the palestin
Ambassador do you disagree with Hamas
being prescribed as a get my point
please get my point I want to see equal
treatment and I will accept the equal
rules if these rules are applied on the
the on the Israelis I would raise my
hand and accept I but my hand heart let
me say this to you do you consider
Israel to be a terrorist let me say this
to you that's number one number two I'll
ask you do you accept the UK you ask me
about the UK government the UK
designates Palestine as the occupied
Palestinian territory right opt we are
occupied do you accept that design but
it's an interesting question about
occupation isn't it that's your
government I think the Palestinians have
lived in a very repressive so it's not
occupation well it's it's a repression
right what it's they are living don't
accept International they are living as
oppressed people I I have I have for
years ressed by what well they're
oppressed by by Israel effectively
keeping people trapped in Gaza right and
they have the ability as they've shown
him the last few days to turn on and off
water to turn on and off food supply I
think all this is wrong what about what
about those Bank Ambassador I think it's
all wrong but let me just ask no no no
this is a major point it's a inter me is
it is it an occupation Ambassador you're
not interviewing me what you're trying
to do if if you don't mind me saying you
are distracting from my original
question it's a conversation
respectfully Ambassador it's a convers I
was interested that you last night
demanding that political leaders like K
stama condemn a a supposed attack by
Israelis on a hospital which now looks
like it wasn't by Israelis and I'm
simply saying to you keep repeating this
parting this how doador let me finish my
question how do you know it's not by
isra I don't how do you know so don't
say it but nor do you I am I know what
I'm saying I represent the situation you
do not know it was an Israeli hold me
accountable next time you're neutral
you're neutral I am neutral I'm not
neutral okay I get that so no no no you
are being biased that is honest you are
taking the isra side no I'm not you are
I'm not saying you are following the
queue from isra I'm not okay I'm saying
the BBC verify unit has said tonight I
think do you think they're impartial in
this or not they shouldn't this is they
won't even call Hamas terrorist this is
none of their business this is the
business of Karim Khan the prosecutor
I'm going to ask you one more time and
you don't have to answer this question
if you don't want to it's entirely down
to you but given that last night you
wanted people to condemn what happened
last night in your belief that it was
Israel air strike and you were ferocious
in demanding that repeatedly will you
now take the opportunity to condemn what
Hamas did in October the 7 final I only
ask you one more time 22 Arab states
convened at the beginning of this
including my state my government and
they condemned do you personally condemn
it they condemned the killing of
civilians from all sides you know what
is all sides from all sides do you
condemn what happened October why you so
reluctant to you asked you asked you the
one last night demanding people tell
I'll I'll tell you what I would be the
first to condemn if I ever saw you
asking an Israeli official to condemn
did you ask the ambassador to condemn
all the atrocities I will be asking I'll
tell you I will be asking the
representative of the ambassad you had
the Ambassador before me you did not ask
her to condemn anything then you didn't
watch the interview I did yeah I did
okay let me ask you one more time I did
cuz I'm not sure if you heard my
question I will not answer this question
unless you allow me to explain no that's
fine you don't have to answer it no no
no I'll tell you but if you're not going
to answer it don't demand that other
people condemn things and certainly
don't ask me to condemn things if you
won't condemn 1400 people over me our
position our position how can you not
condemn what they did our position is
very clear I represent the Palestinian
leadership and people I represent the
PLO that's the sole legitimate represent
representation of the Palestinian people
president Mahmud Abbas the government
Hamas is not part I know of the
government okay that's number one number
two that legitimate representation I
represent have committed for 30 years
for first nonviolence and negotiations I
belong to that camp you are you're
you're asking the wrong person committed
to International resolutions and
committed to the recognition of Israel
we recognize the state of Israel long
before anyone else and we still waiting
for Israel's recognition of us and guess
what happened in this 30 years every
political Avenue was blocked every legal
Avenue like the icj and the ICC is
blocked every hope for any Palestinian
is blocked you are talking to a person
who religiously believe in nonviolence
so please don't ask me that question if
you believe nonviolence Ambassador why
you Rel you believe in nonviolence
that's why I Pi why you so reluctant why
I want to become an because I believe in
the power I believe in the power of
diplomacy I believe in the power of
nonviolence I believe that we should
always return and maintain the moral
High ground but that's why I am
answering the way I'm answering that's
why I'm challenging you because because
the moment I accept your question is the
moment I accept we are the instigators
of violence we are the aggressors and I
asked you the question before I she
didn't say that no I didn't say that to
you I understand you're not part of
Hamas no no no no no not me not me only
the entire Palestinian people are the
instigators understand you're not they
question I understand you're not H let
me explain Pierce please but understand
cool down cool down the moment I accept
this logic of condemnation in the lack
of Israeli officials being asked by you
and everybody else to them that moment I
accept that my people are lesser of a
people that we are not equal that we are
lesser of a you know children of our God
and I don't believe that okay no I I
think and I think I think no I think
Palestinian people are absolutely
entitled to fairness and equality and
human rights many of the things they've
been deprived of for decades I would
love to see peace in the Middle East but
nobody can show me how what Hamas did in
October the 7 has done anything for the
Palestinian people other than set
everything back
peace even more unlik the moment I see
that Equity that balance you I'll be the
first to use any word you want but so
long as there is this imbalance this
racism against Palestinians this
consideration of us of being of being
you know one but racist against
Palestinian no no I think there are
people who are racist I think anti-
Palestinian ism is flourishing
everywhere I think we are seen as to be
less of value than the Israeli lives
I'll tell you how I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why you brought me here you're
bringing everybody this has been the
focus of everyone you have located your
moral compass on the 7th of October no
no did you locate your did you locate
your moral compass that says to me did
you locate your moral compass 200 people
killed this year in the Westbank cover
did you bring me to discuss the many
Palestinians who were killed only in the
last few months this is the that's
that's what I'm to you okay I've been a
journalist for 30 years I've run major
national newspapers I had a Daily Show
at CNN for four years if you actually go
back and look at what I did including
for example a 2-year campaign against
the Iraq War which I thought was an
illegal invasion of a Middle Eastern
country so please do not pigeonhole me
as somebody that has no compassion for
Palestinian people no don't generalize
you you oppos the war I've been getting
Palestinians on all week I've been
giving Palestinians platforms including
you all week right but when Israelis
were harmed you see this is what I'm
telling you why into being Palestinians
when hundreds thousands of Palestinians
killed by settler militias K Ambassador
here's my answer I can guarantee you
absolutely guarantee you that if the
Israelis ever carried out a terror
attack of the nature we saw on October
the 7th they doing what they they killed
1948 they pulled Holocaust Survivors out
of out of their homes and kept them
hostage they shot babies in their in
their cribs watch the terminology they
burned families alive deliberately going
in to get civilians you see you see you
see your responsibility is to really use
the the right terminology why this is
all of the words all that happened you
you are invoking many things here you've
just invoked terrorism you are now
invoking Isis you don't dispute it with
a terrorist you are now invoking Isis
and you spoke about I haven't mentioned
Isis but for the record not with you but
for the record I do believe there's a
parallel between what Hamas has done on
October the 7th and Isis that's that no
no no I'm okay you see you don't agree
the Israeli look what happened on the
7th of October is not condoned we reject
wholeheartedly the targeting of
civilians our culture our upbringing who
we are as Palestinian Christian and
Muslims what happened is nonp
Palestinian how is that and we reject it
and we want to continue maintaining the
moral grounds of our cause very right
let me ask you this okay okay let me let
me continue let me continue okay
okay however since the
7th of October this the first moment
Israel started preparing and putting
together a huge campaign to delegitimize
the Palestinian people to link Hamas to
Isis and then link Hamas to the
Palestinian people then link the
Palestinian people to Isis then do the
ethnic cleansing and the mass
destruction and the mass murder you are
following on your okay that's exactly
what happened then the international
media mainstream media were literally
following the cues following the cues
Isis you you you talked about Iraq all
the time Isis is a group of criminals
who gathered from all over mercenaries
who were there to kill and only to kill
with no real agenda you agree yes you
think Palestinians are that don't you
think we have a political and legal case
to make but I think so why are we using
this term we are using these terms to
allow the Israeli War Machine to kill
Mass that's why we are using let me
respond so everybody who use these words
is complient Ambassador let me respond
everyone respond okay respond please I
do not believe that most Palestinian
people support what Hamas did on October
the 7th I do not believe you do I do not
believe the Palestinian Authority does
so do not think for a moment that I
think you're all the same I think Hamas
is a terror group who committed an act
of unspeakable depravity and terrorism
and they must be held accountable the
question is what is an acceptable way to
hold them accountable I do not believe
full ground Invasion will do anything
but make this 10 times worse for the
record but let me ask you this there are
200 hostages I think 199 hostages been
kept by Hamas should they be released
they they include children they include
Holocaust Survivors what is your view
yeah all hostages should be released
first of all they should be keep safe
and protected and they should be
released but hostages from all sides how
do we get to P we have five we have
5,000 hostages in Israeli jail also
including children and women we have
many of them who are rounded there
without charge or Tri everybody has to
be released i' got to wrap this the
final
question how do we get to peace from
here it seems to me after 30 years of
covering this conflict we've never been
further away from peace between Israel
and Palestine how do we get to peace
here by
listening from your heart and your brain
that this is a people struggle for 106
years 106 years because it all started
here the Al for declaration by the
British Empire where they promised our
land without consulting us and they
turned Us in that 67 words into
non-jewish
minorities we were 98% of the population
we had lived there for Millennia we were
the cardal of civilization we produced
every Prophet Palestine is the
birthplace of Christianity we were
literally The Hub of the region the
linkage between Europe Asia and Africa
and all of a sudden we are only a
non-jewish
minorities and then Britain took over
our land and not only they denied our
people's Hood the nation Hood in 1917
but they denied US during the Mandate
our statehood because the the the
contract with the league of nation was
Britain will come and take Mandate of
Palestine to prepare us and to recognize
us as a state as Palestine you know what
happened in the nakba and the mass
expulsion the the Jewish Milas at the
time ethnically cleansed 2third of our
nation including hisory including my own
parents so history and have great
Sympathy by the way with what happened
since then my people 67 and the military
occupation that we discussed since then
this is a people's struggle for freedom
for justice for equality this is a
people's cry to survive how do we get to
peace uh uh by by full application of
international rules we did not create
the post World War II two solution yes
of course Israel has to end its
occupation that began in 1967 Refugee
Rights must be respected in accordance
with International uh law two neighborly
countries can get into together with
neighborly uh relations but the
Palestinian people have the right to Def
defense defend themselves and a state we
don't have an army a state has an army a
state will do so so occupation is the
root cause of all this discussion I have
to end it there we've had half an hour I
appreciate you coming in thank you very
much I understand the passion as you say
you're not you know you're not an
impartial person in this I understand
that and I wish your family all the very
best in Gaza I really I mean that very
sincerely thank you I hope they're okay
thank you thank you for coming
in on S next to here from an Israeli
government spokesman and as Israel
prepares a ground offensive in Gaza with
the lives of many hostages perhaps on
the line I'll hear from the former head
of the British
[Music]
army
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
welcome back to p on sens I'm joined now
in the studio by the Israeli Diplomat
and spokesperson oie gmid and the former
head of the British army Lord Dan well
welcome to both of you um oie let me
start with you your reaction to my
interview with the Palestinian
Ambassador um you know after uh the
horrors that have been uh committed by
Hamas against uh Israelis on the 7th of
o October it's very disturbing to see
his reaction it is so difficult for him
to condemn Hamas actions um and I have
to say as someone who cares for the
Palestinian people he should be fighting
against Hamas which are holding the
Palestinian people hostages and they are
making them suffer both the Palestinians
and both
Israelis the big question I've been
having this all week with multiple
voices uh on all sides of this debate
but the big question I don't dispute for
a moment I read a column about this
yesterday I read that Israel has an
absolute right to defend itself after
what happened this was an appalling
terror attack the worst attack on Jewish
people since holog the worst terror
attack you could say since 9/11 so they
have a right to defend themselves and
clearly if the enemy is Hamas and Hamas
is predominantly in Northern Gaza living
amongst civilians the only way to get
Hamas is to go in there in some way
whether it be through air or ground or
whatever it may be and I'll come to the
general to talk about what the the
consequences of that may be but the key
question is proportionate what is
proportionate I don't even know how you
find proportion when you're talking
about the scale of what happened on
October the 7th but Israel will know
that the world is watching and if they
get this calculation wrong and they act
in a way the World Views as
disproportionate then this could spark a
situation 10 times worse than it is
already what do you say to that and
Pierce you said it yourself what is
proportion to beheading of people to the
murder of um
1,400 people to the to the torture of so
many people to the um um firing alive
those innocent uh babies women uh
elderly people it's it's it's a question
what is proportionate to that I have to
say you know I think thank God we're not
going to be proportionate like the Hamas
was with us because we are not like
Hamas we care about human lives we do
not Target civilians we target Hamas
facilities Hamas infrastructures Hamas
leadership and we don't want to be
proportionate can you say unequivocally
that it was not an Israeli air strike
that hit the hospital last night you've
seen the evidence provided by the IDF I
can say equivocally that it was not an
Israel air strike there are proofs you
know that the size of the crater uh the
the fact that there was no IDF activity
at that time in that place um and the
firing the the the the the footage that
we saw from Al jazer itself plus the
conversation that we picked up from
people from Hamas saying it was us it
was said in Arabic it was us it was uh
it was it was Islamic Jihad who fired
that and and you know maybe people don't
know but out of the the the the hundred
thousands of rockets fired uh from the
Gaza Strip towards Israel at least 30%
are uh um misfired and they fall within
the Gaza Street I mean I'm going to be
uh you know
waiting for more official confirmation
of this but Lord Dan I mean
the the impending sense there's going to
be a massive ground maybe air ground sea
invasion of Gaza from a military
perspective I saw uh David betrus who
was obviously commanded the Allied
Forces in Iraq talking about how this
brings back the memories of what
happened in Iraq and how incredibly
difficult it is to fight an urban War
like
that and David betr is absolutely right
and it is very difficult to fight an
urban War like that back to the issue of
proportionality um the IDF can be
proportionate provided its operations
are to the maximum degree possible
intelligence L um if they think they're
going to be able to find lots of hammer
Fighters amongst the residual civilian
population I think they'll be
disappointed because actually anyone
with half a wit would blend into the
civilian population what they absolutely
must do and undoubtedly will do knowing
that there's a great network of tunnels
where lots of Munitions and all all the
rest of it as store is find them destroy
them and if they can find any control
centers we destroy them as well and if
if along the way they're able to round
up any Hass Fighters and leaders so much
the better but a lot of civilians are
going to die Aren't They At what point
as as I asked OE at what point does
proportionate become disproportionate it
becomes
disproportionate if to the watching
world the actions of the IDF are not as
careful and measured as they can
possibly be of course in any situation
you're going to use violence you're
going to use force and there will be
that awful term some degree of
collateral damage but so long as that's
kept to the minimum and it really does
come back to this issue of the of the
hospital being being struck
yesterday it is a CH is a hospital
that's run by the church of England it's
run by the dasis of Jerusalem it was
struck on Saturday last week and the
dasis of Jerusalem got in touch with the
Israeli government and said that's our
hospital um I'm absolutely certain that
any clear thinking military Planner on
IDF side would not then strike at
hospital again and of course the other
side this gets back to exactly the issue
of proportionality of course they'd want
to strike that of course they'd want to
kill as many people as they can but it's
so easy to blame it on the IDF and the
whole world's narrative changes and
that's what's got to be change back the
other
way
wellie people are already saying three
and a half to 4,000 Palestinians have
already died that's just in 10 days
since what happened so that is nearly
three times the death toll of October
the 7th with every image we see of a
dead child in Gaza of a dead woman
whatever it may be the anger grows
amongst the Muslim population around the
world but seeing that today um how does
peace get found through all this how do
you get to
peace you know there's something I want
to raise here because for the last 11
days and and we saw that even more so
yesterday evening and today in the in
the headlines many mainstream uh um
broadcast and newspaper decide to use
Hamas lines as official Palestinians say
when we know that Hamas have been the
one who've been murdering us and and and
have no uh Mercy for Israelis for Jews
they still hold at least 200 people
Israelis hostages we don't know the
situation so to take Hamas as an
official uh um uh s source of
information I think is really worrying
um I think journalists today need to
really think about the headline that
they choose and the wording that they
choose and if they're not sure about
some information they need to verify I
was shocked last night I'll be honest
when I was seeing the BBC and ITN and
others all just assuming it was an
Israeli airra because Hamas told them I
mean I found that absolutely Reckless
and and if I if I can uh add the words
that they're choosing have implications
throughout the whole of course we saw
the implications you saw immediate
protests breaking out outside Israeli
embassies all around the region these
are dangerous consequences of Reckless
talk um
General we look at this with very Bleak
Hearts I think um you know the the
prospect for peace has never seemed
further away but also the prospect for
this spiraling out of control into
something much more serious also seems
to have never been more potentially a
scenario we should look for what do you
feel well I think her right and of
course the sadness is go back just a few
weeks and months then there was a
warming of relations between Israel and
Saudi Arabia in the UAE and that was
actually very hopeful now who was going
to stand to lose out of that basically
it's it's Iran yes so we know that Iran
has a major influence over Hamas but you
you raised the issue of escalation the
thing that really worries me is
Hezbollah in in Souther in southern
Lebanon yeah the last time I was in isra
Israel it was made quite clear to me
that the amount of rocketry and missiles
that hezar has got could cover and
strike the whole length and breadth of
of of of Israel and the Iron Dome system
as good as it is runs the risk of being
overwhelmed and the idef made it quite
clear to me that if that happened they
really have no option but to retaliate
in a major way and that might even
include um striking Targets in in Iran
so we absolutely have to hope and pray
that this does not escalate and I think
Iran is benefiting to a degree that
we're now seeing a cooling of
relationships between Israel and Saudi
Arabia in the UAE but I think that's as
far as they probably want to go because
if there's a real meltdown then Iran is
going to find itself really isolated and
um we mustn't forget President Biden
flew across but there's two carrier
groups in the Eastern Mediterranean the
United States is investing itself very
heavily in a military and obvious way
and also saying very closely to Israel
we support you yeah Richi sunak on his
way there now um I I think it's tragic
that a lot of major media organizations
that should have known better jumped a
conclusion
unverified um which increasingly looks
like the least likely conclusion
actually I mean the BBC's verified group
appeared to have almost established
beyond beyond much doubt actually that
this was highly likely to have come from
inside Gaza and if you stop to think
about it that was always likely to be
the outcome I mean what did the IDF have
to gain nothing they're actually much
clever they're much better at targeting
them that you did not need to put a
large explosive ordinance into a a
Christian run um Hospital which had
thousands of people taking shelter there
it it just defies any kind of military
logic well done it good to leave you
there thank you very much indeed for
coming in oie go thank you very much
indeed for coming I appreciate it
uncensored next President Biden placed
today that the world will not do nothing
how far should the US and the world go
to support
[Music]
Israel we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about toour
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
Ry sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pompous you mean
you're not going to support mayor Jose
L stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid consults don't really know
what they're doing
the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't
what he was most of them seem to have
given up
welcome to the talk it's really great to
be back my Little Darlings kids think
all they have to do is stay at home be
silly take pictures of everything just
shut down Tik Tok then yeah problem
problem
solved fit as a butcher's dog there you
go he's fit as a butcher's dog all right
but but he's now middle class three us
here T the KnockOn effect is far larger
than just CO2 I nearly have empathy when
I'm speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after show
after
call say I'm not I'm not a Swifty
critics I'd say me included got former
PMS all over the joint saying things the
last few days we have indeed yeah great
first show you having fun oh a ton of
fun King PE and King Cube I think it's
only WR for one king you know what I'm
saying just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk when I say I am
God you think I'm joking or not you tell
me I'm not joking I'd rather do it on
camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing why we'll explain why
how do you feel about that influence
that you have you better be careful
we're coming for your children there
buddy they medic Nation yes I'm going to
do you're going to Res yes cuz I cannot
continue my work it was a fabulous
dinner until you two uh mooned us thank
God for talk TV is not only the home of
common sense it's the only place where
you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV
[Music]
welcome back my pack with me talk to me
contributor Esther kren political
journalist AV Santina and from America
Fox Nation host Tommy Lon let me start
with you Tommy because I'm going to say
something that I know will horrify you
um but I thought Joe Biden did quite a
good job today a in continuing to come
across uh to uh the region when a lot of
his supposed hosts pulled out uh which
could have been seen as embarrassing for
him but also getting some humanitarian
commitment from Israel and perhaps
offering some calming perspective of
what is a very incendiary situation your
thoughts to me offering a a modum of
praise to President
Biden uh you know I appreciate it
because I'm an American so I would hope
that our president looks strong to the
rest of the world so I'm glad that you
had that takeway uh unfortunately I did
not when I saw him sitting on stage with
Benjamin Netanyahu and fumbling through
index cards probably written by a
green-haired intern I was honestly
embarrassed uh furthermore referring to
Hamas as the other team was also quite
embarrassing for me to watch I'm happy
that our president has had steadfast
commitment to Israel and has pushed back
at members of our own Congress who have
been seemingly Pro Hamas I am happy
about that also though a little
Disturbed that he has committed a100
million of our taxpayer dollars to go to
what he refers to as a humanitarian
effort in Palestine and in Gaza uh
assuring us that would go to civilians
and not terrorists though giving us no
indication of how he would be able to
separate the two just as he told us that
that $6 billion dollars that he unfroze
to Iran would not be used for terrorism
I'm not sure how he can assure us of
that but I'm happy to see that there are
some folks on the other side of the pond
that think our president looks strong um
here in America that might not be the
case for us watch watching all of this
unfold I had a sneaking feeling you
wouldn't necessarily agree with me um
let me come to to you Esther you were
just saying in the break an interesting
thing it's it's been an awful yeah since
October the 7th we've all felt a real
sense of Heartache of what we're
watching fear about what may happen next
yeah it's it's been awful and you know
the thing is because there is such a
potential for this to become
catastrophic in an allout Regional war
and potentially a World War actually the
bar is pretty low so yes I do agree with
you in the sense that Joe Biden didn't
you know completely destroy things um
but the bar is very low I mean this is
still a doding old man he described
Hamas which effectively was were
responsible for firing um the misfire
into that hospital car park as the other
team this is not a game of Monopoly
they're no clear winners and losers here
and for him to you know it would take a
stroke of diplomatic genius for him to
be able to properly relay the the the
the the complicated nature of this
crisis and he's just not up to the task
there's so many things he's not up to
the task for unfortunately this is the
President we that we have at the helm of
this crisis we just have to hope he
doesn't make things worse AA this whole
thing now comes down to me to what is a
proportionate response by Israel to the
atrocities we saw on October the 7th
there are many on the left who simply
don't want to be seen to condemn uh
publicly what happened on October which
I find staggering I mean just a human
being just has to condemn what happened
but what is a proportionate response
what is Israel supposed to do in the
wake of such a horrific Ric series of
attacks well as someone with no military
background I don't think I'm the one to
answer that question and I do think but
morally what do you think they should
morally I do think the left have
condemned Hamas and I do think you know
Hamas are terrorists and I do think that
is something the left are say the
argument which has changed dramatically
this week is now about humanitarian Aid
last week it looked like we weren't
going to assist in getting any Aid into
Gaza and I think that was a huge concern
for people The Narrative on that has
changed now I actually and it's Chang
because of President Biden's visit I
think well I I was going to say I agree
with Tommy Lauren there actually today
actually made me quite proud to be
British because I thought that sun act
today at Prime Minister's questions I
thought that was a real president I
thought sorry prime minister I thought
that was Statesman like I thought not
taking a decision or not taking an
opinion or a view on that hospital
bombing until you were absolutely
certain I think that's exactly where the
West should be but you know the thing is
I think you know the talk about
humanitarian Aid which is important is
no longer good enough there needs to be
we need to stop failing the Palestinians
because that is what has driven them I
mean Hamas haven't had elections
2006 see I would say that sentence is
problematic for me because I think the
plight of the Palestinians has been
horrific for a long time right nobody
with a brain I think thinks otherwise
this has to be sorted it has to be
resolved yeah but you cannot use that as
an excuse no but that that pulling hoca
grandmothers Hamas are terrorists and
they need to be destroyed EX in the
reality there's no excuse but Israel
will not Prosper if Palestine doesn't
that is the real
Palestinian leaders have failed their
own people Mahmud Abbas is worth
hundreds of millions of dollars of
course there are questions of whether
all this humanitarian Aid is going to go
to the right PE people it obviously will
not but the reality is because the focus
has not been actually getting the
Palestinians the kind of leadership what
they deserve where money isn't being you
know funneled into Rockets F to be fired
into Israel instead of proper leadership
into into a a cohesive police force for
instance Israel will never be safe it
will never Prosper neither will the
Palestinians and unfortunately this has
just reminded us how important that is
to to to Okay I accept that let's let's
completely change uh topic because it's
been a very serious show and Tommy I
want to bring in you here because
Richard Curtis who wrote Love Actually
and Notting Hill and all these great uh
cheesy films which I love by the way um
is come out and said he was stupid and
wrong for doing fat jokes right in some
of these films uh and it's because his
daughter is clearly pretty woke Scarlet
she uh she said to me you could never
use the word fat again in my generation
calling someone chubby was funny like in
love at there were jokes about that
they're not funny anymore now I'm not
exactly size zero and I've had a lot of
female panelists co-hosts over the years
do little chubby jokes and you know what
it makes me do a I laugh and B I go to
the gym uh it has a double beneficial
effect on my well-being and health Tommy
are we getting just ridiculously
oversensitive should we not just be able
to still laugh about people if they're
chubby
yeah there are far worse things to be
called than fat or chubby but I'm
actually far more concerned about the
glorification of obesity certainly
something that we do here in the United
States a lot we look at lizo as some
kind of an icon because she is grossly
overweight so when we're talking about
hurting people's feelings that's one
thing when you talk about encouraging
unhealthy Lifestyles and diabetes that's
quite the other so you know fat chubby
it doesn't make people feel nice but
when you glorify obesity that's actually
putting people in real danger we're
gonna choose between the two yeah I
wrote a colum about this last week
exactly on that point um AA it's
interesting there has been a weird kind
of move to celebrate being morbidly
obese and by that I mean Cosmo putting
people on the cover who were like you
know 280 pound and 5 foot tall where
they're clearly killing themselves
through their enormous weight and yet
they are celebrated like this is body
positive it's not why are we doing this
I mean we did that for how many years
what 20 30 years before that hero and
Chic I agree with just as damaging no
but that but that's what it is for for
most women who are on those covers you
know most women aren't naturally a size
six to eight which is what you need to
be on you know to be on the front page
of a magazine and actually they are
killing themselves in the same way that
you argue that if people are larger
they're not healthy neither are the
skinny I I think they're both they're
both equally harmful but on this Richard
Curtis thing I just read I love Richard
Curtis I think he's an absolute genius
and there family uh but I sort of
groaned and went if I listened to
everything my kids told me right about
what I shouldn't shouldn't do on this
program I I mean it would just be a
total disaster I told it's cowardly
because always but some we can't judge
people now based on the standards of the
past we keep doing this with slavery
with with you know reparations all of
that we keep saying oh they were so
terrible and I don't laugh at fat people
therefore I'm better guess what it's not
news to fat people that they're fat
right the fact that they're not people
you may not make jokes about them in
your comedy doesn't negate the fact that
when they look in the mirror they see a
large person and to pretend like it's
it's it's it's a beautiful thing that
lizo is so beautiful because she's
attractive if I told you you look like
lizo you would punch me because that is
not a complement in any way shape or
form that is true you would it's it's
true and you don't look like lizard you
a healthy beautiful like woman so let's
stop pretending he may not want to make
jokes I would pass any comments about
any of you in an aesthetic way because I
would have to then March myself to Human
Resources but it's not to see you all
thank you very much indeed Tommy great
to see you over there uh it was great to
do your show other day as well brilliant
show thoroughly enjoyed it thank you
very much and thanks for coming on again
on Pi Morgan uncensor thank you to the
pat that's it from me whatever you're up
to Keep It Uncensored good
[Music]
night
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just St
out me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about toour
today we do it all sunak SW
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid concerns don't really know
what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson Zoom back
into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't what
he was most of them seem to have given
up welcome to the talk it's really great
to be back my Little Darlings kids think
all they have to do is stay at home be
silly take pictures of everything just
shut down Tik Tock then yeah problem
problem solved
fit as a butcher's dog there you go he's
fit as a butcher's dog